it's great to welcome to the program
today Ronnie bee who is founder of the
Idaho Bitcoin group and Loch Ness crypto
dot-com is an educator has been an
advocate for Bitcoin and crypto
currencies dated all the way back to
2012 so that 2012 is interesting I
actually remember meeting some of the
first crypto advocates that I knew knew
personally at that time or even a little
bit before what was it originally that
drew you to the space yeah so I think
you know I had a background as a PHP web
developer I was doing a lot of database
interface and also payment gateways and
the problem with the payment gateways
back then words they were atrocious it
was brutal to install payment systems
especially as you went into the late
nineties oh that was my bread and butter
back then and when I'd heard about
Bitcoin and I immediately downloaded the
client I looked at the white paper I
read through well you know every every
line of code on the client orig the
original client and I saw the problem
that it solved and it was at that point
I said it was kind of that that aha
moment I said Mike my goodness there is
just no reason to use credit cards to
use any type of intermediary for
payments I said this is this is crazy
what's been invented what's been solved
here but the funny part was I went on
for the next six months
still with the idea that it was it was
just good for Internet and website so
it's kind of comical I went for six
months and then after six months I said
hey you know Costco could use Bitcoin
and so could Walmart and then you know
so it took me probably like a full year
before I I started to realize like how
big Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies were
gonna be so it was a pretty awesome
moment and just every day that I was in
the space I kept doing more math and
realizing how big this was actually
gonna be so let's dig right into one of
the main areas of disagreement which is
hacks and security I mean I my view on
this is not all the way to one side or
all the way to the other side I don't
think that any time I hear a claim that
anything is unhackable I'm skeptical of
that claim because in history dating
back to you know drum messages sent
between villages that were
were intercepted and modified every time
there's a new technology of any kind it
is to some degree subject to hacking or
interference on the other hand I also
don't necessarily think that there it is
a particularly hackable status quo to
cryptocurrency there have been major
hacks and and thefts right billions of
dollars from different places there's
mount GOx there are many others so what
what is a sort of more rational
perspective on the hack ability and
security of Bitcoin and other ledger
crypto currencies so first off we you
know myself as a educator I have to be
really careful about how we respond to
these types of questions because the
confirmation biases that people have
really will root deep and really ossify
their idea so if I were to say to you
that yes a cryptocurrency is hackable
but if we're looking at a scale of
probability like that's the problem like
you might need a thousand years and all
the computers on the planet to hack one
cryptocurrency wallet address the
problem is if I say that to you a
person's confirmation bias a person is
more ignorant on the space they
immediately take that and say oh I can
hack Bitcoin and so it starts to
propagate the wrong message yeah I mean
I think it's important to say at the
same time if you hear that if someone
hears you say that and their frequency
of notion is that it's effectively
unhackable
it might also boost that preconceived
notion where there's where they say well
Ronnie's saying it's hypothetical II
possible but would require a thousand
years of computing power right yeah it's
it's a really tough situation that
weren't because this technology is
escaping the capacity the capacity of
most people's understanding including
myself including most computer
scientists so but but you you broached a
very critical and important topic and
the topic is third party intermediate
intermediaries or custodians custodial
accounts where that that is yesteryears
technology that you know we used to use
banks or at least us Kryptonians that
are moving into the new system banks are
not equipped or like in the case of
mount gox's exchanges these custodial
accounts they're not designed for
two currencies in the same way that the
the credit card was not designed to be
used on the internet and that's why you
know these hacks in these these credit
card thefts are so prolific is because
it's very easy it's an old-fashioned
technology being used in in the new
space and so here we have
cryptocurrencies which are designed to
be used peer to peer person a person
without an intermediary but instead
people are giving the custodian or the
exchange their private keys all of their
access credentials and so it's a giant
honeypot a huge amazing target of wealth
for any type of adversary any type of
hacker so can you can you give us a
sense if you know the percentages if we
talk about all hacks and thefts what
portion would be attributed to an
individual making a mistake with their
keys passwords or otherwise being
socially engineered versus true hacks
that are taking place
technologically so I don't have I'm not
going to have an exact stat a good
number for you I'll say that to date I
personally myself with the ID o Bitcoin
group just in Bitcoin we've helped
people recover about 10 million dollars
worth of just Bitcoin I'm not talking
about any of the other cryptocurrencies
and in all cases and every single one of
those cases it was tremendous user
errors user incompetency now I still
have plenty of friends that lost a lot
of money in Mount GOx and cripsy and
several these other exchanges but but
the thing is there's no resolution you
know so so it's kind of unfair for me to
say we've helped you know rescue X
amount of funds and the percentage is
100 cent because you don't there really
isn't a resolution if mount GOx goes
offline you know you really can't get
terribly involved with the the rescue
process there so so it's one-sided
because of what you you know what you
actually can touch what you actually can
do so these many of these currencies
although some are very new many of these
have now been around many years there is
a view that exists i don't know how
prevalent it is that the sort of wave to
ride the prices up has come and gone and
now it's more a question of
can transaction fees be kept low enough
and speeds high enough to make some of
these Kryptos valuable for or useful for
transactions are these stores of value
that are relatively safe as you and I
are talking about do you agree with that
paradigm or do you think that it's still
an open question as to what the future
holds for the value of some of the major
crypto is including Bitcoin well I think
as long as we have capitalism and an
open market where price discovery can
occur then yes this is what we've always
seen with pure capitalism is that if
something is inefficient and someone can
do it better or different coin can come
along and do it better then yeah that's
that's where the money moves that's
where the people move I mean
productivity right I mean that's at the
end of the day that's kind of where
things will be driven so if transaction
costs do go too high then no people
won't use it but what we have to
understand with bitcoin is it is working
really well as a store of value and a
transfer of wealth and the fees
associated with the problem is this is
the first time that people have ever
become aware that they are paying fees
so when we use our credit cards at the
grocery store you know at Walmart let's
say we buy milk
Walmart charges you the fee but you
don't see it because they just increased
the prices of milk and so this is this
is kind of the tough part is people
don't understand that they're actually
going to end up paying a lot less and
fees but since it's highly visible it's
kind of a pain point right now so we
might have to fix that but no to answer
your question if if the system is
unaffordable or inefficient then it
won't work the market will come to the
right resolution the the thing is
without having all these kind of
rent-seeking natures these third-party
custodial accounts that take value out
of the system that kind of usurp that
value without having those guys in play
this can become one of the most
efficient economic economic systems
we've ever I mean just look at look at
the cost alone of if I have to transfer
a hundred thousand dollars over to
someone in Sweden that's a terribly
expensive and slow process so right now
let me explore that though isn't is it
because we do I mean with our
advertisers and advertisers we represent
there will very often be
you know international transfers that
just take three days and cost 30 bucks
for a wire like in what sense I mean we
haven't done a hundred thousand dollars
but the the fee does not seem to be
related to the amount that we're
transferring well in what sense is it so
expensive what you're saying I've not
seen that well I think just what you
said I think that's pretty expensive
thirty dollars to send any amount of
money anywhere and you can do that much
more inexpensively a matter of fact if
you're sophisticated sophisticated
enough you can do it for free you could
transfer keys or there's a few different
methods you could use I don't want to go
too deep into it now but we're going
deep I mean my so tell me maybe I'm just
missing the the picture there was a
while where Bitcoin transaction fees
were 20 bucks even for small amounts of
money so when I think about that and
then I think about I can wire a hundred
grand for 30 bucks to Switzerland that
seems comparatively cheap but maybe I'm
misunderstanding some part of it well
okay so so you said $100 so if I need to
give you $100 and you need to have it
instantly one solution could be that I
could send you the private key to a
public address that has $100 worth of
Bitcoin in it then you have it instantly
instantaneously you can do whatever you
want with it there's no fees associated
with that whatsoever zero okay so like
for example if I link PayPal to my
checking account I can also send it
instantly for no fee a hundred bucks I'm
talking about now I guess so what I'm
saying is it seems to me that the value
does depend on what's going on in the
space where at some points in the last
five years bitcoin transfers have been
extremely inexpensive or even free but
then at other times transaction fees
have increased significantly it seems
that that stability there would be a big
boon to the level of adoption of these
technologies so let me answer it with a
couple different points first off yes
the last of the old technology is always
better than the first of the new
technology so yeah we're still going
through these growing pains for me
personally I mean you said PayPal
let's see PayPal let's see was type
typhoon there was a a affiliate
marketing company in 2015 I believe with
about a hundred sixty million dollars in
their accounts and this is what they pay
their affiliate marketers with PayPal
froze that account
under the guise of we're investigating
and we've dealt listen we have dealt
with that as well so it was not an
offensive paypal of any kind other than
providing an example right but but so
these are things if you're gonna dive
into the world of PayPal and say it's
more efficient than we have to look at
it is it truly more efficient on the
aggregate and so here's the here's the
deal you're you're right there are use
cases where you'll be better off with a
paypal or on venom or whatever right now
because that's the best of the old world
technology but if you look at all the
things they're coming I mean here's
here's the crazy thing think about this
just for a minute
we haven't even built anything in the
Crypt I mean really really I mean
Walmart's not using any type of
cryptocurrency Costco is not using any
type of cryptocurrency
we haven't done anything with these
cryptocurrencies and this is normal this
is the normal technological growth
process think about this cell phones are
50 plus years right around 50 years old
your your personal computer 50 plus
years old the internet 50 play and if we
think about cell phones cell phones took
40 years like more than four decades
before they started to become cool
before you could actually communicate
with a satellite and get directions
before you could use the internet on
them I mean 40 plus years Bitcoin
bitcoin is only ten years old and only
Bitcoin all the other cryptocurrencies
are brand-new even the copycats a
Bitcoin like you know like litecoin like
dogecoin those are still relatively new
compared to Bitcoin Bitcoin itself has
only had ten years we still need to get
10 20 30 years down the road from where
we are now and then there'll be no no
way to compare a PayPal there'd be no
way to say you know I can do this with
PayPal I can do this with Facebook coin
because the cryptocurrencies will have
had 30 years of maturity and growth and
application time will certainly tell
them that that's a very interesting
perspective let's talk a little bit
about what I think may be negative
forces within the space and two things
that come to mind to me are using
massive computer power or computing
power for mining which we know has a
significant climate impact and date
taking advantage often algorithmically
of patterns in order to very quickly
make trades to eke out small gain
ideally gains rather than losses if
you're doing it right I guess what's
your sense of those two mechanisms
within the world of crypto mining and
day trading positive negative neutral
unclear so well so it that's that's
really tough because it's both so first
off let me say that we couldn't be where
we are and we can't do without the two
of them the day traders and the miners
so speculators do subsidize the system
heavily they add a lot of liquidity so
it's a it's a really interesting
juxtaposition the two sides of it the
problem is that the majority of new
entrants and by the way at any one point
in time almost about 70% of our mass our
new entrance like entrants that don't
even know how to operate a hardware
wallet don't know you know how to open
exchange account except so I mean I
really mean brand new people it's the
equivalent of a 13 year old who hasn't
started driving yet in the US I mean
that that that's what we're talking
about and so when we look at this
condition the problem is the new people
come in and they say well bitcoin is ten
thousand dollars I've missed the boat oh
but I can mine or I can day trade my way
to a billion dollars and so you have
these people that that literally don't
it can't even run command line on a
Linux operating system and they jump in
and start mining or they buy mining
shares or they're duped into some sort
of mining Ponzi scheme so these are the
problems or they think they can day
trade and they talk about you know
Fibonacci retracements or double a lot
of dips or retesting numbers and so no
you can't cryptocurrencies are very much
in the words of one of the our local
crypto guys marcus downing he says
cryptocurrencies are like a bar of soap
the more you use them the more you move
around the less you have of it because
of kind of as you alluded to earlier
these fees so here's a deal everybody
complains about the electricity and
mining listen that again is a free
market and it will keep equilibrium with
where it needs to but you can't argue
now if you say that we're put
value in the form of electricity
hardware and human resources and you
know human capital into mining that
there's not that's not you know the
value proposition starts there you have
so many people that say that
cryptocurrencies aren't backed that's
one of the origins of the value you know
that we're in putting into these
cryptocurrencies it takes you know some
sort of capital to start with to build
the crypto yes I would say so here's the
where I would you and I have a lot of
agreement here but where I would
disagree on the electricity piece is
number one the the utility industry is
not a free market and there are actually
good reasons why it's not and and we
could debate that but but let's not jump
into that piece but there's another
thing there are significant negative
externalities to the amount of energy
that we use particularly when it's
linked to fossil fuels so I do think
that there is a case to be made that yes
your miners are paying for the
electricity so in that sense they're
paying for it they're getting it and
they're using it to produce something
that for them provides value but to the
world given what we know about the
burning of fossil fuels there is a
difference between saying okay we're
going to use fossil fuels in order to
achieve a vs. we're going to use them to
achieve B and B maybe mining
cryptocurrency that is I think a fair
debate to have
so yeah agreed to two good points to add
to that is first off all the
cryptocurrency mining companies that
were working with they're trying to
build their own photovoltaic plants the
reason being is it's more efficient to
keep the current in DC and get it right
to the miners at source as opposed to
have a power plant generate and then
push the electrons through wires get
them to the company so there's about a
three to one loss if you and tropically
there's about a three to one loss like
three electrons produced equals one
electron at the miner
versus if you do it locally with
photovoltaics that's the first component
the second component is cryptocurrencies
are going to eliminate the need for
banks and banking infrastructure so my
question to you is if we take the banks
around the globe everybody says the the
most recent articles they said Bitcoin
mining was using the electricity of
Sweden or some small country and so my
question to you is
how much electricity are the banks and
banking infrastructure and think about
they are hacking targets all the
security all the Internet infrastructure
made these are data farms Matt just
massive data farms how much electricity
are all of that all of that
infrastructure sucking up and nobody's
done that number because that's a huge
huge number that would swallow up
anything cryptocurrencies are doing so
well but I think that it's a bit it's a
fair thought experiment but I think in
practice when you understand the
interest that government have in
continuing to prop up legacy banking
institutions I don't really see a
scenario in which Bitcoin eliminates
banks I think that if anything you would
see banks have to adjust to the reality
of cryptocurrency and they would change
and shift but I don't know that we would
say well we can eliminate the entire
carbon footprint of banks because
they'll go away I don't think that
that's likely
well you I guess you're right if we use
Craigslist as the example Craigslist
sucked out about six billion dollars out
of the classified-ad markets for
newspapers and we still see newspaper
company stay not as many yeah but but
when you have a legacy empire that has
that much economic inertia yeah it takes
decades to go out of business Kmart
Sears all these mega stores they took
decades to finally go out of business
they had so much economic inertia that
they're standing on but the banks I
don't see why that would be any
different we this is what we've seen
time and time again where's blockbusters
where is Kodak there's over 2,000 auto
manufacturers here in the USA that are
out of business today that nobody even
knows the names of if you go to
Wikipedia and say automobile
manufacturers that are out of business
there was an automobile manufacturer
called Apple there was one called one
two three there's been so many car
companies in the USA that have gone out
of business and nobody knows that we
know Ford Chevy maybe although in
fairness it could be that if we said how
many that actually sold a hundred cars
are out of business all of a sudden the
number of goes way down so I think if
you have it if you have a design for a
car are you an out of business car
company maybe but the point is still the
same one as well taken yeah yeah and
Touche Davey all right you're it's good
and quick with those analogies okay
we've been speaking with Ronnie be the
founder of
Bitcoin group and Loch Ness crypto calm
very interesting conversation on what I
believe are some of the most important
discussions about the future of this
space Ronnie really appreciate your time
in you talking to me today yeah Dave and
I appreciate your show I appreciate
everything you do but watch you for a
long time
thanks for everything as well my
pleasure